ينضم إلي الآن يول جانسي، وهو
زميل كبير في المعهد الإسرائيلي
لدراسات الأمن القومي. يول، من الجيد
رؤيتك، لذا تحدث إلينا عن كيفية تحول
الحوثيين، وهم مجموعة صغيرة نسبيًا من
مقاتلي الميليشيات، من مصدر
إزعاج إقليمي لإسرائيل إلى مجرد مصدر إزعاج
حقيقي لإسرائيل.  تهديد أمني إقليمي
حيث يكون لديك الولايات المتحدة
تحرف الصواريخ ويمكن أن يكون لها
تأثير حقيقي محتمل على
الاقتصاد العالمي نظرا لتصرفاتهم الأخيرة
تماما أه وترى واحدة تراها
الآن حتى تهديد عالمي أه
للشحن الدولي والتجارة
التجارة البحرية بدأوا أه  كقوة يمنية داخلية
أه غيلية أو ميليشيا استولت
على اليمن وبدأت في قتال السعوديين
عام 2015 أو حتى قبل ذلك
وأصبحت الآن مشكلة إقليمية بدأوا
بإطلاق النار على إسرائيل بعد أيام قليلة من
7 أكتوبر ومنذ ذلك الحين لم يتوقفوا
حتى أه أه  أه محاط بهذا
التحالف الدولي الذي بنته الولايات المتحدة أه
مؤخرًا حسنًا، لا يوجد حب
ضائع من الحوثيين تجاه إسرائيل على ما
أعتقد إذا كان على
علمهم حيث يقول الموت لإسرائيل
URS لليهود ولكن لماذا على وجه التحديد
تورطوا  أنفسهم في هذه الحرب وهل
هذا بسبب علاقاتهم مع
إيران وربما، كما قيل في
مقابلات سابقة، يشعرون ببعض
الالتزام تجاه إيران لتصبح مصدر
إزعاج إقليمي
ويقلقك، فأنت على حق تمامًا، فقد
أرادوا إظهار التضامن مع إيران
لدفع تكاليفها.  لقد
دعمتهم إيران لسنوات عديدة،
وأرادوا أيضًا إظهار التضامن مع
الفلسطينيين، لكنني سأخبركم المزيد،
وأعتقد أنهم يريدون أيضًا إظهار
قوتهم، مما يسمح للسعوديين
والأمريكيين بالحصول على يد أفضل لكسب
النفوذ.  في التفاوض هم الآن
أه أه يتعاملون مع السعوديين حول
مستقبل وقف إطلاق النار أه في
شبه الجزيرة العربية